he is rolling stone's chief television
critic and the co-author of the soprano
sessions along with
uh his friend matt zoller seitz who i
believe has been on the show before
but we welcome alan steppenwell to the
program how are you alan
i'm great rich how you doing i do
believe i just set the stage
i do believe i've set the stage here
okay alan so let's get to the um
a few things first things first the the
interview the interview that went crazy
yesterday was actually conducted with
david chase several months ago correct
years ago this was the book came out in
january of 2019
and we did the interview uh sometime in
2018 in the spring
so this is an old interview it basically
what happened was
when the book came out someone published
a story
summarizing that section of it
misinterpreting what was actually said
that aggregation then went viral for a
few weeks there
people wrote about it we did interviews
saying no that's not actually what
happened
and then it went away and then suddenly
a couple of different publications
over um when the anniversary hit earlier
this week decided all right well let's
look it up
and they just wound up referring to that
first story and i believe the
independence
yes like going to the primary source so
it's like a copy of a copy of a copy
it's a game of telephone and they're all
missing
the whole point of it so now let's
straighten it out allen let's
straighten it out so
walk me through the conversation you had
with david chase about this very scene
at hand alan so i mean you already laid
out a bunch of it we were not actually
preparing to talk
up to him about the scene at the ice
cream parlor that day
because we did a bunch of interviews
with him and we knew that we would have
to save that for the very end
because he hates talking about it and
then accidentally we stumbled into it i
was just talking about the idea
of when he was doing the next to last
season whether he was making any plans
for how the show would end
and he says well you know i had that
death scene in mind for a couple of
years before we shot it and we
point out what he said and he said after
you guys but then he very quickly says
but that's not what we did
and he makes clear that when he says
death scene he's referring to this idea
of tony going
to capitulate to johnny sack he goes
through the lincoln tunnel heading into
new york
and we never find out what happens and
he decided to do something
more ambiguous he didn't want whether or
not tony dies
is sort of up to the audience rather
than up to the show
i would argue okay so now then
him saying he was the the death scene
that he had in mind
was him going to capitulate to johnny
sack and then everything goes dark but
he thought the going dark
would lead too many people to believe
what he was intending that tony was
going to die
correct yeah it was he he was being too
blatant with it and i think
ultimately he wanted the end of the show
to be more about the larger
idea of mortality and the fact that for
any of us
it could come at any moment whether or
not we're a boss of a new jersey crime
family
and so he wanted you to feel as you're
in the ice cream parlor
that sense of tension that sense of doom
that sense of oh my god
at any moment you know his life could be
snatched away because at any moment any
of ours could
whether or not that's actually the
moment where tony dies is not even
something that i think david chase is
that interested in
so i understand he may not be interested
but the rest of the world is alan so
let's keep this conversation going
so if he thought that going dark meant
being dead why isn't going dark at the
end of this episode
not the same thing well originally he
was actually going to go
he said it a couple of different ways
with us he said at first he thought like
when he went to the tunnel
it might he might go to white instead of
black
and the idea being basically like the
division of heaven
and you know when people see a light at
the end of the tunnel and tony is
literally
coming to the end of the tunnel and
there's light uh and he decided that
that was too much
and so instead he did this cut to black
he did this in a scene where tony is
otherwise
not apparently in danger he has just won
a war against philliotardo
nobody wants him dead he's made peace
with butchie the new boss of new york so
everything's fine and yet things are
tense because of the way he shot it and
the way he edited and the way he keeps
cutting
to meadow trying to park the car alan
steppenwall rolling stone chief
television critic and co-author of the
soprano sessions here on the rich eisen
show
so the conversation i was having with my
friends across the aisle yesterday
uh centered around not only referring to
that death scene
and they're pointing out well he's
referring to a scene that he
opted not to do so therefore
tony the going dark cannot be
uh insinuated as him being dead even
though
that is exactly how david chase said the
quote-unquote death scene that he did
have in mind was going to end we can
place
that aside for the moment my way of
saying when he said
f you guys and everybody and you guys
start laughing and then he joins in
laughing again
sure sounds like to me when it reads on
the page to use the phrase allen
yeah uh sure sounds like to me like me
getting busted in the conversation with
my buddies
trying to avoid answering something
and they call me out on me letting
something slip
that sounds like that f you guys these
guys
read it off the page to mean no f you
guys you can't
insinuate what i said and i know you're
going to try and use it against me
how did he say f you guys
in the context alan
i think i felt in the moment
like it was more the former the idea
that
he had let something slip without
intending and we had not even
necessarily set him up to slip i was
when i asked that question i had no idea
that those words were going to come out
of his mouth
and so in that moment that's what it
felt like but then the more he talked
about it and the more detail he went
into
the idea of the johnny sax scene it did
feel more ultimately like he was chasing
don't put words in my mouth
because he's trying to avoid
right and now you've sort of you you've
got me to do it and i've said the wrong
thing
right that's what it sounds like to me
because i don't want this f you guys
just to be another version of
interpreting what the going black means
here
there's got to be some sort of certainty
and you
believe you got him and he spends the
next few
minutes trying to throw sand in those
gears because
again if he says because
just to put it all in context chris
albrecht who ran hbo
at the time said to him hey you know
uh what do you think about wrapping this
up and
you want more time and he said yes and
he said basically
that's when he decided to map out the
end he knew he had
two more years left right and that's
when he came up with that death scene
and he referred to johnny sack and tony
going to capitulate
and going black and he decided not to do
that
you then said hey that's the death you
do realize you referred to the
that death scene and then he said f you
guys so putting it all in contacts
together
how in the world is tony soprano alive
right now alan i mean 20 years later
tony soprano is probably not alive just
giving the lifestyle he lived and the
fatty food
i meant to the diner that very night
allen and i'm not saying that he had a
heart attack
based on another one of his panic
attacks because he had another hamburger
i mean like literally the
members only jacket guy went into the uh
the bathroom
like al pacino and the godfather and
took something from behind the uh
took something from behind the um the
toilet and did something
you know what i'm saying so this is what
i'm talking about here
i mean it's certainly possible like if
someone if someone comes away from that
scene
saying all right members only guy whack
tony i'm not saying you're wrong to
think that
but but the show deliberately ends
before anything happens
and it leaves that up to you and it
makes you feel
like death could be coming but it
doesn't actually say that death is
coming
because none of us ever knows exactly
when that's going to be for us
uh and to me it's it's more interesting
to leave it in that ambiguous space but
if you want to answer do you want to say
that he's dead there's a lot of evidence
supporting that if you want to know why
he's not dead i would say among other
things
nobody wants him dead right then he's
all of his enemies have either
died themselves or made peace with them
you know
his empire is kind of ruined and you
know paulie walnuts is his only guy left
but he's doing okay
there's nobody there that wants to whack
him and there's not there's no story
in the course of the show that usually
did not do big twists on the audience it
didn't
withhold secrets from us if someone was
plotting to kill tony
we would have seen that so that i would
say is the counter argument
and so you have the idea that maybe his
punishment is that he dies or maybe his
punishment
is that he just has to go on and on and
on and on being tony soprano
who is we have seven seasons worth of
evidence is a really miserable person
who hates himself in his life all right
alan steppenwall if you are
the uh you're in the robe uh sitting on
the high court of uh
rolling stone uh chief television critic
um you've heard all the evidence you've
seen all the evidence it's placed in
front of you you've even you've even
heard
what appears to be and admissible in
court
slip of the tongue and suddenly that's
admissible
okay i place in front of you
in this court of television opinion
is tony soprano alive the jury comes
back and
delivers to you the verdict and you say
what you're the foreman let's say you're
not the judge
you're the foreman of this jury alan
what do you got
is he alive or dead i think we're a hung
jury i think we can't come up with a
verdict
it's a mistrial it's a win for us that's
a win i'll take that
a mistrial is not a win for you a
mistrial is a win
we got to go back in again we're good
that's a win
like the casino it pushes away alan
don't make me call up the vulture.com
article in which you actually said he's
dead don't make me go to the transcripts
if you read that article all the way to
the end yeah the last line of it is me
saying that he's obviously alive
no i didn't go all the way out and i was
trying to explain the rich
and i was trying to explain to them that
they don't kill i cannot take
more losses from this chair they don't
kill the maf
mafi does not kill in front of the
family it's done alone
alan i i think that there are ways in
which she could certainly be murdered
by members only guy that he could have
had a heart attack there there's also
ways in which she paid you know meadow
comes in they eat he pays the check and
he goes home
and two days later the fbi arrests him
because carlo has turned rat there's all
sorts of things
that could happen and you know what matt
liked to say mike my co-author matt
zelda sites
his initial reaction to the show is oh
the audience just got whacked
you know all this talk about you never
hear it happen
like that was coming for us because the
story ends
so our life as sopranos viewers has just
come
to an abrupt and shocking effort yeah i
think he's dead allen
i think that's what it means i mean why
what's the ambiguity
and really what's the now let me ask you
this um was there any thought at all
of before um gandolfini's passing
of uh maybe doing it again
um or continuing it on and then that
chase wanted to at least leave
something open for that no he's he's
been very clear with me
every time we've spoken in all the years
since the show ended
that that had played no role in it he
said you know originally he said if he
ever wanted to revisit it he would do
something in the 1960s which is what
he's doing
with this movie the many saints of
newark which is going to be about
christopher's father
yeah around the time of the newark riots
but he also said if he ever actually
wanted to tell another tony soprano
story
what he would do is he would find some
moment in between
seasons or even in between episodes from
seasons
and like here's an untold adventure of
tony you know at this moment in the show
huh so um fascinating
what's your friend oh gosh i don't even
know what to say right now because i
think he's dead
but that's fine i guess that's the whole
part of the conversation
but he did refer you you got him though
he said f you guys i've been in
conversations like that that is
you got him you got him and he didn't
intend to do it and you got him
alan you got him all i will say is the b
side of of don't stop believing on the
jukebox yes
is any way you want it yeah now that's
purposeful like he really puts that on
yeah no that was
that was a complete accident but he
looked at that
that worked for me that works
come on what's your favorite episode of
the sopranos
if you had a name one one one one out
off at the top allen what do you have
what's your favorite uh long-term
parking which is the end of the adriana
and christopher story
brilliant just absolutely brilliant no
question about that
you know that that was so moving that
was so
amazing that was quite something
all of it from start to finish you know
uh the pine barrens was pretty damn good
too yeah right it was another great way
to add no pine barrens is great the
college episode with meadow in season
one basically
made the sopranos into the sopranos it's
it's maybe the greatest show ever made
it's fantastic
and uh okay before i let you go alan um
your favorite show on tv now is what
right now would probably better call
saul the the breaking bad spin-off which
just wrapped up its fifth season and
it's just
like somehow as good as breaking bad at
this point which i never would have
expected to be possible yeah i agree
with you i thought the second to last
episode
of this season where um where saul's
going through the desert with mike urban
trout was
uh was as good as any breaking bad
episode that was as close to a breaking
bad episode as better call saul has
gotten
at this point it's a wonderful show it
really really is and i've got david
costa bill on in the final hour of this
show uh he plays gail
from from those shows breaking bad and
better call saul
what do you think of billions do you
like it oh billy's is a lot of fun and
he literally gets to twirl his mustache
on that show that's a great part for him
no he does i know he does he kind of
he'd kind of choose the scenery
okay alan i appreciate the time um
i don't appreciate that i couldn't give
you more satisfaction there richard i
tried you know what alan it's just
i i i i honestly believe
it's open and shut but i guess that's
the whole part of the conversation
that i think now the sopranos was never
very interested in open and shut things
it really loved ambiguity
and it loved to make people crazy with
its ambiguity still doing it 13 years
later
all right alan let's keep calling let's
keep having a conversation not just
about this but about all the pop culture
stuff we talk about on this show i hope
uh
i hope i hope to get you back on soon
absolutely you gotta follow me
seppenwall on both twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here